le mauvais coups des anglais à airbus
ils veulent faire construire le train
d'atterrissage l'a340 par un
constructeur américain le consortium
européen fondé moins 20 morts dans les
accidents de plongée depuis le début de
l'année six fois plus que l'an dernier
le grand bleu donne peut-être de
mauvaise idée
aïe et riant à paris le militant
nationaliste arménien été expulsé
d'union soviétique il y a dix jours il
défend la cause du nagorny karabakh
charles pasqua invités de ce journal
lance ministre de l'intérieur répond à
l'actuel pierre joxe notamment sur les
machines à sous dans les caisses
bonsoir les anglais vont il trahi airbus
les anglais vous le savez sont partie
prenante dans le consortium européen qui
exploite l'avion or on vient d'apprendre
que les britanniques sans demander
l'avis de leurs partenaires
s'apprêterait à confier la construction
du train d'atterrissage du nouvel airbus
a340 à une société américaine celle là
même qui fabrique déjà les trains des
boeing ce serait en quelque sorte le
loup dans la bergerie
c'est un député des pyrénées-atlantiques
michel inchauspé qui a révélé la faire
il s'occupe des crédits de l'aviation
civile à l'assemblée
reportage patrick esther daniel f le
principal intérêt politique et
économique pour airbus industrie c'est
de pouvoir construire les différents
éléments de l'avion en europe un pari
difficile qu'il faut absolument gagner
pour pouvoir attaquer sérieusement le
géant américain boeing
ainsi jusqu'ici les trains
d'atterrissage des a300 a310 et a320 été
réalisée par la société française
messier hispano bugatti en association
avec les anglais d'authie avec le
développement d'un nouvel appareil de la
gamme
l'a340 long-courrier kadri réacteurs
tout devait se passer de la même façon
sauf que quelques semaines avant les
remises d'appel d'offre officielle
les anglais de petits ont dénoncé
l'accord avec les français et se sont
associés avec le numéro un mondial du
train d'atterrissage
l'américain clip blanc étions chargés de
faire de préparer le dossier dont ils
ont eu la connaissance de tous nos
dossiers et donc le fait qu'il nous ait
quittés au dernier moment quinze jours
avant la remise de l'offre présente pour
nous effectivement un préjudice
extrêmement grave
faut dire que nous sommes depuis le
début des activités airbus c'est à dire
depuis 15 ans
grand spécialiste des trains
d'atterrissage pour un avion gros
porteur nous est un marché important et
nous entendons pouvoir rester dans ce
marché qu'on peut évaluer à 10 ont
l'équivalent d'un travail le 900
personnes pendant dix ans du travail
pour 900 personnes pendant dix ans et
alors si le marché vous échappe
là c'est ce travail qui disparaît si le
consortium européen ne bloque pas
rapidement toute la sphère l'américain
cleveland qui a pour premier client
boeing va détenir le monopole mondial
des trains d'atterrissage
pire dans les mois qui viennent boeing
va probablement racheter cleveland
ainsi airbus pourrait se trouver
totalement dépendant de boeing bravooo
les anglais attention attention si vous
prenez la route ce week-end les
contrôles seront nombreux et c'est vers
le gouvernement vient d'adresser un
télex à tous les préfets pour faire
respecter le code de la route sans
hésiter à distribuer amende et
suppression du permis de conduire il
faut dire que les chiffres du week end
dernier ont été dramatiques vous le
savez il ya eu 135 morts une
augmentation de 70% par rapport à l'an
dernier
autre contrôle particulièrement sérieux
pendant cette période d'été les
contrôles de prix et de qualité dans les
magasins la direction de la concurrence
qui dépend du ministère des finances
vient de rendre son rapport elle relève
toutes les pratiques litigieuses dans ce
domaine comment sont effectués ces
contrôles notamment sur la qualité des
produits enquête de christophe martin et
pascal golomer un drôle d'appétit jugez
plutôt
oui on nous avons commencé par un peu
d'huile de friture sur l'huile de
friture c'est le test favori des
contrôleurs de la direction de la
consommation et de la concurrence
une huile trop vieille brûlé et ça peut
être
l'intoxication alimentaire fait l'huile
de friture c'est la bête noire des
contrôleurs mais aussi des cuisines mal
tenu des aliments avariés
les chambres froides incertaine ou des
notes trop salée
autre champ d'action les grandes
surfaces ici ce sont surtout les
produits frais qui sont l'objet de
toutes les attentions température de
conservation de 2 à 4 degrés centigrades
on va vérifier que la température et de
conservation est bonne
le verdict tombe le réfrigérateur est à
18 degrés une des infractions les plus
courantes et qui peut aboutir un procès
verbal
pour vérifier la qualité et la
conformité des produits
le travail du laboratoire est
indispensable l'année dernière près de
4000 analyses microbiologiques ont été
effectués 46% des produits étaient de
qualité insuffisante
c'est le cas notamment de certaines
pâtisseries à la crème pour lesquels il
n'est pas rare que nous soyons amenés à
relever des charges proviennent
relativement élevé a conclu rabais da
donner des conclusions de non conformité
dans certains cas nous avons ce que nous
appelons des produits dits corrompu et
dans ces conditions de vent tendus ils
doivent être retirés du marché
cette année cent mille contrôles seront
effectués pendant les vacances sur la
qualité mais aussi sur le bon affichage
des prix
de quoi donner la chair de poule aux
professionnels peu scrupuleux
la folie de l'été sur les plages les
machines à sous dans certains casinos
elles sont autorisées depuis cette année
et c'est la ruée hier soir c'est cannes
qui a inauguré 150 machines au casino
municipal
pourtant ces machines à sous ne font pas
plaisir à tout le monde avant-hier le
ministre de l'intérieur pierre joxe
invités de ce journal a dit qu'il
appliquerait la loi votée par la
majorité précédente mais il a dit que
c'était une mauvaise loi
comment la france en est venu à
autoriser les machines à sous qui existe
déjà dans beaucoup de pays européens
rappel historique rémy roche c'est la
loi du 5 août 1987 qui autorise sous
certaines conditions l'exploitation des
machines à sous en france
voté par le rpr l'udf et le front
national
elle modifie celle de juillet 83 qui en
prohibant toute utilisation
le 6 mai dernier soit 48 heures avant le
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle charles pasqua alors
ministre de l'intérieur lève le dernier
obstacle à l'arrivée effective des
bandits manchots
il signe le décret d'agrément des
sociétés fournissant et assurant la
maintenance des machines
auparavant il avait donné son accord à
une première liste de 16 casinos
autorisés à ouvrir des salles de
machines à sous
les autorisations qui comme pour les
autres jeux de casinos sont temporaires
et ne sont pas automatiquement
renouvelables sur les 137 casinos
français plusieurs dizaines
d'établissements qui espère un ballon
d'oxygène financier de ces machines à
sous ont également déposé des demandes
d'autorisation
après instruction elles devront à leur
tour être signé par pierre joxe
le nouveau ministre de l'intérieur qui
en la matière semble vouloir se hâter
lentement
charles pasqua bonsoir bonsoir le
président du groupe rpr au sénat mais
c'est vous qui en tant que ministre de
l'intérieur avait eu l'initiative de
l'arrivée des machines à sous en france
alors j'aimerais vous poser une question
pourquoi vous avez fait cela c'est
seulement pour faire plaisir aux
français qui aiment le jeu non pas pour
faire plaisir aux français qui aiment le
jeu le jeu mais tout simplement parce
que l'association des villes thermales
dans lesquels sont installées et les
casinos autorisées se plaignaient aussi
bien auprès du ministère de l'intérieur
mais surtout auprès du ministère des
finances et du ministère du budget des
conditions financières qui leur étaient
faites et de la gestion difficile à
laquelle il était confronté d'autre part
il est bien évident que les machines à
sous et est autorisé dans la plupart des
autres pays en france à faire là là là
dans une enclave proche de la france qui
est monaco on en trouve également il y
avait donc une grosse pression une
demande importante
j'ai entendu dire que le ministre actuel
ce matin la haute banque
nous sommes également été lentement
parce qu'il a fallu près d'une heure
avant que cette affaire arrive à son
terme
on dit aussi que c'est un bon moyen pour
lutter contre le grand banditisme qui
profitait des profits donc dû des
machines à sous clandestines non non non
je crois qu'il n'y avait plus de
machines à sous clandestines en france
il n'y avait pas d'autre part sont quand
même des recettes limitées faut pas se
faire trop d'illusions j'avais
l'impression que pierre joxe l'actuel
ministre de l'intérieur c'est donc votre
successeur mais c'était aussi votre
prédécesseur
elle est politique et si voilà vous avez
l'impression qu'il veut défaire tout ce
que vous avez fait il ya aussi notamment
la sphère de la querelle de l'école de
police d'egletons par exemple oui ça
c'est vrai alors je dirais d'abord que
chaque mise en intérieur est libre
d'apprécier les choses comme il en
retard mais en fait la première des
choses que l'on fait en me lisent à
l'intérieur c'est d'appliquer la loi et
d'autre part de ne prend pas de mesures
intempestives alors j'ai entendu la
polémique qui s'est engagé à propos
d'égletons on a dit qu'on ne pouvait pas
installer une école de police parce que
c'était un endroit reculé parce que il
ne fallait pas d'école où il est une
formation uniquement pour une catégorie
de policiers mais que ce soit ont
contraint une école polyvalente
tous ces arguments en réalité ne résiste
pas une minute
un examen sérieux je constate tout
d'abord qu'il le ton est une ville dans
laquelle il y à déjà
un environnement important en matière de
formation il y a centre national de
formation des adultes y ayez à l'école
nationale du bâtiment
en tout il ya quatre écoles lahe soir à
lille dont on parle lorsque nous avons
décidé de faire une école de police pour
les policiers auxiliaires d'abord mais
naturellement elle avait vocation à
devenir une école polyvalente
c'est parce qu'elle se situait dans
l'environnement dans l'environnement
immédiat de clermont-ferrand où se
trouve le centre national de formation
de la police mais aussi parce que nous
avions comme une conception d'implanter
le les école nationale de police enp
provence
et contrairement à ce que pense le
ministre de l'intérieur actuel nous le
faisions cela qu'aller dans le sens de
ce que font la plupart des pays
européens prônent l angleterre les
écoles de police ont toutes implantées
dans de petites villes où les tentations
sont moins grandes et où les gens
peuvent s'adonner vraiment à l'étude et
rien d'autre alors vous avez
l'impression que pierre joxe veut
embêter jacques chirac et la corrèze où
j'ai l'impression tous les cas qu'il ne
se préoccupe pas outre mesure de lui
faire plaisir mais ça va coûter cher
puisque la ville avait fait des
investissements qu'il faudra le
rembourser
les marchés avaient été passés avec les
entreprises
ça relève donc probablement d'un mauvais
coup politique et aussi d'une mauvaise
gestion
l'ouverture avec avec michel rocard et
pierre joxe par exemple c'est pas pour
vous je ne crois pas du tout à
l'ouverture je ne crois pas
naturellement qu'ils aient leur côté les
bons et de l'autre les mauvais et je ne
crois pas non plus que la france soit
coupée en deux parce que ce sont plutôt
les français qui seront coupés en deux
chacun entre l'eau et une bonne gauche
un peu de droite selon les moments
selon les instants mais je crois que
sous le mot d'ouverture on a surtout
voulu
jouer un peu les attrape nigaud alors
justement il ya débat risque qui sont
entrés au gouvernement il y aura jamais
de rpr au gouvernement d'euros car je
crois qu'on ne peut pas dire qu'il y a
des baristas gouvernement ou en tous les
cas que les baril se sont d'entrée au
gouvernement il y en a quelques uns
monsieur soleil arrose hommes politiques
qui étaient dans cette mouvance qui sont
très peu nombreux qui ont cédé au chant
des sirènes
aucun rpr ne cédera rochereau paul dites
moi que tu encore aucun sdf non plus que
pensez vous des propositions de jean
marie le pen pour les prochaines
municipales il propose un accord rpr udf
front national que les ratons n'aurons
pas d'accord national il n'y a pas lieu
qu'il y a des vous dites actions
nationales mais il pourrait y avoir des
accords locaux
je crois d'abord que les élections
municipales sont des élections locales
avec le front national
je crois que nous avons eu le tort de ne
pas débattre au fond des problèmes il y
a des choses qui nous sépare elles sont
importantes il faut le lire et nous
avons eu le tort également de l'est
s'est défendue par le front national un
certain nombre de thèmes qui sont ceux
de la grande majorité des français
qu'ils soient de droite ou de gauche
et aussi nous avons eu le tort de
laisser le front national
défendons pratiquement seul certain
nombre de sujets qui ont trait à la aux
conditions de vie des français de tous
les jours mais ça veut dire pour en
revenir aux municipales qu'un des
accords locaux avec eux avec non pas
d'accord le coup je crois qu'il n'y aura
ni accord national liant accor locale
mais si dans telle ou telle ville
certains de nos amis considèrent qu'ils
doivent prendre heure ou deux membres du
front national sur leur liste
ce sera à eux de dean pas d'apprécier la
situation et ensuite de s'en expliquer
monsieur pasqua puisque nous arrivons à
la fin de cet entretien c'est de ce sera
ma dernière question puisque vous
faisiez votre autocritique qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ceux qui vont geler
jamais fait de mon nom vous avez dit
nous avons eu tort de faire ceci pour la
sieste je veux dire que c'était une
forme d'autocritique alors qu'est ce que
vous entendez que nous avons eu tort de
ne pas rappeler que dans la vie on doit
conduire l'action politique en fonction
des idées auquel on est attaché
et ce sont ces idées là qu'il faut
défendre on ne se déterminera en
fonction de l'idée du voisin simplement
très rapidement donc qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui pensent y en a aussi
au rpr je sais qu'ils pensent que si
jacques chirac a échoué aux
présidentielles c'est à cause de charles
pasqua
ce serait trop facile pour me comme
l'explication est comme argument nord je
crois que si nous avons échoué aux
élections présidentielles c'est
probablement parce que nous avons oublié
qu'on n'est pas élu parce qu'on fait une
bonne gestion que les français ont
besoin d'autre chose hommes besoin un
peu de romantisme
ils ont besoin de rêve est manifestement
françois beat torrent su le faire mieux
que nous merci charles pasqua le reste
de l'actualité maintenant et tout
d'abord le plaidoyer d'un arménien pour
son pays il s'agit dahiri quillan ce
militant nationaliste expulsé d'union
soviétique il ya une dizaine de jours et
déchu de sa citoyenneté soviétique
il était l'un des leaders du mouvement
arménien il vient d'arriver en france ce
matin à paris il a dit qu'il allait
demander un visa soviétique pour
retourner dans sa patrie
et puis vous allez le voir il a aussi
donné son point de vue sur les problèmes
actuels en arménie et en particulier au
nagorny karabakh
louis carzou c'est en arménie se
sublimer comme en février dernier la
crise nationaliste la plus grave de
l'air gorbatchev à l'origine une simple
revendication territoriale le
rattachement à l'arménie du haut
karabakh région peuplée à 75%
d'arméniens mais attribuée par staline à
la république d azerbaïdjan l'explosion
devient inévitable lorsque surviennent
les massacres d'arméniens par les
azerbaïdjanais dans plusieurs villes du
haut karabakh
les manifestations prennent alors une
ampleur sans précédent et c'est sous la
pression de la rue que le parlement
arménien à la mi juin décident de voter
le rattachement territorial
réponse immédiate du parlement
azerbaïdjanais un vote pour le statu quo
des frontières moscou est alors obligé
de trancher
début juillet le soviet suprême oppose
un niet catégorique revendications
arméniennes et landre doit être rétabli
les autorités soviétiques décide alors
d'expulser le leader nationaliste par où
ira eric y en qui a passé 18 ans de sa
vie en prison
arrêté dès le mois de mars il n'a pu
participer qu'aux premières
manifestations aujourd'hui réfugié à
paris
il témoigne ça c'était au début quand il
y avait encore des portraits de
gorbatchev
ils ont disparu quelques jours plus tard
après le communiqué officiel de l'agent
stas disant je peux le comité central
considérer ce mouvement comme étant le
fait d'un groupuscule d'extrémistes
quelle est votre réaction personnelle
face à votre expulsion
c'est une atteinte aux droits de l'homme
un homme a le droit de vivre où il le
souhaite
mais c'est aussi une atteinte au droit
des nations car c'est en fait le
président du parti d'union nationaliste
qui est visé avez vous encore de
l'espoir pour le haut karabakh
tant que la population n'est pas
exterminer je garde espoir
mon principe dans la vie et que
l'impossible n'existe pas
geste en cisjordanie c'est toujours
l'inquiétude après la décision du roi
hussein il a licencié 21 mille
fonctionnaires qui ne seront donc plus
payés par la jordanie
un problème sérieux pour toutes ces
familles parmi les licenciés il ya aussi
des notables des hauts fonctionnaires
charles enderlin les va rencontrer les
plus durement touchés par la rupture
avec la jordanie
ce sont les notables palestiniens qui
avaient bâti leur carrière politique sur
les liens avec le royaume hachémite à
jérusalem est
le rédacteur en chef du quotidien pro
jordanien and are strange hydril c'est
vraiment une tragédie nous sommes
abandonnés
espérons que l'ol paie sera relevé le
défi acceptera de porter le fardeau qui
assumait jusqu'à présent la jordanie 1,2
à notre destin est lié à la jordanie où
réside la moitié de notre peuple sans
l'unité nous sommes perdus et puis ici
les jeunes ceux qui sont nés après 67
qui manifestent contre l'occupation ne
savent pas ce qu'est la jordanie les
1000 jeunes palestiniens du lycée umba
au nord de jérusalem regretteront
peut-être la jordanie les salaires de
leurs enseignants venait des caisses du
roi jeu mais en fait selon les
spécialistes pour l'ensemble des
palestiniens la portée économique de la
rupture est limitée a pas de ces lycées
de quelques cliniques les médias ne
l'ont pas un impact économique
catastrophique sur les palestiniens les
jordaniens ne représente en effet que
quelques dizaines de millions de dollars
sur un produit national brut de plus
d'un milliard deux cents millions de
dollars le principal souci de la
majorité des palestiniens c'est la
subsistance au quotidien il observe les
appels du comité du soulèvement et les
commerces ne sont ouverts que trois
heures par jour
ces garagistes n'ont pas reçu un seul
client aujourd'hui tu ramènes n'achète
plus de vêtements et sa famille se passe
de viande je n'ai pas le choix dit il je
continuerai s'il le faut jusqu'à la mort
pour être libre on doit payer
on doit sacrifier
après plus de huit mois de soulèvement
la société palestinienne s'est habitué à
une vie économique extrêmement réduite
lira ne désarme pas au contraire les
terroristes irlandais se sont encore
attaqué une caserne britannique en
allemagne il y a quatre blessés hier
lire a encore revendiqué l'exécution de
deux entrepreneurs protestants deux
hommes de 60 ans ils ont été abattus à
la frontière de l'irlande du nord il
effectué des travaux pour la police
britannique
le reste de l'actualité en bref pascal
deschamps arrestation hier soir à
barcelone 2 2 français ravisseurs de la
petite mélodie nakache ya la fille de la
chanteuse kymera enlevé en novembre 87
jean-louis camerini considéré comme le
cerveau du gang et alain coelier avait
réussi à s'échapper lors de l'opération
de police qui avait permis la libération
de la fillette
les avocats du fn ps ont déposé ce matin
une cinquantaine de plaintes contre x à
la demande des habitants de l'île
d'ouvéa des membres des tribus de
gossanah été ôta affirme en effet avoir
été victimes de sévices de la part des
forces de l'anp au lendemain de la prise
d'otage de la gendarmerie de fayaoué en
avril dernier
attentat contre un restaurant libanais à
cannes la nuit dernière
douze personnes ont été légèrement
blessées par l'explosion d'une bombe de
forte puissance dissimulé sur la terrain
du socrates
la déflagration a fait d'importants
dégâts matériels l'attentât n'a toujours
pas été revendiqué les côtes bretonnes
envahies par la marée verte ces petites
algues apparu dans les années 70 n'ont
jamais été aussi nombreuses
capable de détruire tout flore marines
elles se nourrissent de nos déchets
industriels
en attendant que l'on trouve la parade
les baigneurs cherchaient désespérément
la plage le grand bleu c'est l'histoire
d'une passion c'est un superbe film de
luc besson qui raconte la passion d'un
plongeur sous marin
le film a eu du succès il a aussi fait
école semble-t-il cet été sur les côtes
notamment en méditerranée
il y a de plus en plus d'amateurs de
plongée mais attention il y à aussi de
plus en plus d'accidents 20 morts depuis
le début de l'année six fois plus que
l'année dernière
hier encore un allemand se noyer au
large de port cros reportage
emmanuel vanier lubac gravissime
accident de plongée descente à moins 80
m l'ivresse des profondeurs panique
donna des plongeurs remontaient
catastrophe non respect des paliers de
décompression un mort deux blessés
graves
c'était mercredi dernier au large des
îles d'hyères
seul traitement le caisson hyperbare de
l'hôpital militaire de toulon dans cette
droite
ils seront re comprimé exactement comme
lors de la plongée cette heure
d'immersion pour la première séance
d'urgence
sans cette intervention rapide un risque
majeur l'accident neurologie c'était
difficile moteur des visites sensitives
cependant les simplement des gens
paralysé dont l'évolution vers la
guérison et l'accident se produit très
souvent lors d'une remontée trop rapide
les gaz dissous dans le sang sont des
comprimés brutalement des bulles se
forment des bulles qui peuvent aller se
loger dans la moelle épinière ce qui
équivaut à une section de la moelle
conséquence une paralysie très difficile
à traiter en plongée le milieu est
hostile dans ce froid irrespirable une
parfaite condition physique et un
entraînement régulier sont
indispensables mais cela ne suffit pas
toujours
les plongeurs chevronnés sont aussi
victimes d'accidents je suis moniteur de
plongée depuis deux ans je pense très
très souvent et j'ai eu un accident
inexplicable de la part des médecins est
hyper marque qui m'ont traité auquel
sont donc si je peux donner un conseil
aux gens assez de
de plongée en bonne forme surtout pas
après avoir fait la fête et pas trop
profond début de saison vétérinaire et
moniteur de plongée xavier louette a eu
dimanche dernier un accident de
décompression
depuis il est paralysé des membres
inférieurs il n'y a pas de fatalité
je crois qu'on mérite on peut toujours
son accident
moi j'ai vraiment congés dans des
conditions j'aurais pas dû plonger
vraiment fatigué je vois mieux fait de
m'abstenir déjà quatre séances de
plusieurs heures dans le caisson
hyperbare de toulon le traitement sera
très long mais xavier louette n'est pas
sûr de retrouver l'usagé de ses jambes
vingt morts en plongée depuis le début
de la saison 6 fois plus d'accidents que
l'an dernier
les trois caissons de la côte
méditerranéenne sont surchargés les
empreintes génétiques employés peut-être
pour la première fois en france les
gendarmes de l'ain veulent utiliser
cette technique ultramoderne pour
confondre un violeur présumé
ce serait une première en effet en
revanche cette technique est très
fréquente en grande-bretagne maintenant
agnès poirier pour la première fois les
gendarmes vont faire parler les gènes
d'un suspect un prélèvement de sperme de
yaacov mamane violeur présumé va être
envoyé dans ce laboratoire britannique
il sera comparée aux empreinte génétique
laissée sur la victime
la technique a été mise au point par un
généticien britannique alex frei chaque
individu a sa propre carte d'identité
génétique c'est l'adn elle peut être
établie grâce à un prélèvement de sang
de sperme de salive
un fragment de peau ou de cheveux voici
un prélèvement de sperme effectués sur
le corps d'une victime
à côté des empreintes génétiques
reconstitué à partir du sang du violeur
présumé tout à fait identique
ici en revanche on appuie une santé un
suspect car les empreintes génétiques
étaient tout à fait différent des
premières une méthode coûteuse mais très
fréquemment utilisé en grande bretagne
elle permet d'établir de manière quasi
réfutable la culpabilité des suspects le
taux d'erreur 1 pour 1 milliard
automobile formule 1 c'est le grand prix
de hongrie premier essai aujourd'hui de
ce grand prix de hongrie
première séance d'essais officiels on va
les voir j'espère les voilà alain prost
le voici a réalisé le meilleur temps
devant nani et mansell un grand prix qui
s'annonce une fois de plus comme un duel
entre les deux pilotes de mclaren vous
les voyez là mais aujourd'hui ayrton
senna
l'habitué des pole positions a dû céder
dans une première séance d'essai dans
cette première séance d'essais il est
sorti de la route
cet acte est regardée
mende c'est le premier décès dû le
pardon qu'est ce que j'ai dit c'est
senna bien sûr premiers essais du grand
prix de hongrie natation avec trois
nouveaux records de france aux
championnats de france et à dunkerque
alors les voici christophe bordeaux a
battu son deuxième record de france déjà
hier après le 200 m 4 nages il a
aujourd'hui amélioré le record de france
du 200 m papillon le temps deux minutes
une seconde 14 centièmes cécile prunier
elle aussi améliore le record du 400 m
nage libre en 4 minutes 12 secondes et
76 centièmes quant à cédric pénicaud il
améliore de plus d'une seconde le record
du 200 m brasse
demain il y à un tir fait tiercé quarté
+ c'est à deauville
alors voici les pronostics de pierrette
brès le 17 le 11 le 8 le 6 le 7 le 2 et
le 9 fin de cette édition du journal le
prochain rendez vous avec l'information
ce sera au brier de l'air vers 23 heures
mais tout de suite vous avez rendez vous
avec sophie davant qui annoncent
toujours une météo ensoleillée excellent
de soirée sur antenne 2
quoique
abou